ça se passe très croyant vit la présence
de dieu est là les situations les plus
dramatiques peuvent être sublime et avec
amour et partage il ya vous avez perdu
une fille il ya des gens pour qui un
gros malheurs comme ça fait perdre la
foi vous comment vous êtes arrivé à
garder votre foi chrétienne malgré cette
souffrance et murray cette tragédie
j'ai la foi mais je ne comprends pas
tout j'ai eu la foi je sais très bien ce
qui se passe dans le monde
je sais qu'il ya des enfants qui meurent
de la justice il ya va pas revoir à
compter ouvert le journal télévisé en
soit cette région longtemps mais
n'empêche qu'il ya une part de
responsabilité des hommes quand même
quelque part et ma foi n'est pas je
crois en dieu
si vous voulez suivre elle est bien de
temps en temps je m'écroule et jeudi je
vous comprends pas dieu je te comprends
pas mais ça nous empêche pas d'y croire
non demandez aux gens ici savent comment
marche la télévision soit bien embêté
muet dieu je sais pas comment image
encore mais ça ne m'empêche pas d'avoir
et puis bon je vais pas prêt je veux pas
faire une prédication
je veux dire c'est qu'il ya dieu et puis
à jésus-christ c'est sucré nous a laissé
assez de repère pour essayer de vivre
comme il a enseigné et basta le reste
vous savez c'est trop facile de le dire
mais c'est trop compliqué j'ai fait un
pas en avant
c'est déjà pas mal alors il ya un truc
n'ai jamais eu si l'audience papale
et pourtant c'était votre rêve et quand
vous hésitiez comme vous et yaron faut
gérer la cage aux folles the wheel le
producteur vous dis moi je connais bien
le pape je vais te trouver une audience
et c est en fait vous dont vous mais
vous quittez votre costume de zaza
napoli vous mettez un costume bleu
marine une cravate
vous y allez et vous découvrez qu'en
fait c'était pas une audience privée est
d'une audience publique lui rodilhan ce
public on était sept
c'était la récompense du pompage était
très drôle jamais